when this southwest attendant told the
pilot to calm down I told the Southwest
attendant that there was no need for him
to be an today
and then he threw me off the flight he
said I would not be fine
so welcome to my life
Savannah Chrisley allegedly gets kicked
off her flight home Southwest one
Savannah zero
the 25 year old documents her latest
ordeal on Instagram starting with her
experience with an airline attendant at
the gate I went to board my flight to
get on
um and he told me that I had to check my
bag I was like okay I'm gonna if you
wouldn't mind I'm gonna take my bag on
the flight see if I can't make it fit
and if not I'll check it his exact words
were no that's not happening
well the reality star says there was one
person on her side the pilot the
Southwest attendant literally looked at
the pilot the man who is flying our
plane and is responsible for our safety
the most important person within the
Southwest Airlines he looked at him and
said stay out of it no you're not ma'am
you're not flying on this flight
looks like Southwest one because I
didn't fly on that flight
Savannah says she told the employee why
getting back to Nashville was so
important I also stated that I had a 10
year old that I had to absolutely get
home to tonight and while the Southwest
attendant said I don't care
ET reached out to Southwest for comment
after Sav shared this final opinion
Southwest you suck but your pilot was
kind of hot so
never flying you again
and you should probably get together
because your airline sucks majorly it's
okay to be vulnerable and to work
through your emotions as you're talking
about them or in overtime Savannah one
Southwest one I count me three seats
yeah the Chrisley Knows Best star
eventually made it home to her siblings
Chloe and Grayson she's been raising
them while her parents Todd and Julie
Chrisley are away in prison serving a
combined 19-year sentence for tax
evasion and bank fraud you know it sucks
and it's tough but it's the cards that
I've been dealt and those are my parents
so I'm not just gonna give up when the
going gets tough but Savannah hasn't
given up she and Chloe have been
navigating their tough situation with a
lot of laughs school canceled tomorrow
[Music]
all right so we're shopping I don't
prove the top okay why not the top two
o'clock I need to wear a bra with it
what
roasted I should tell you how it is
I don't like that I was like gosh
after doing some research I have come to
realize that it is Chloe
that smells like a Straight Up In and
Out Burger yeah
what do I do put deodorant on
but I don't use it yet well you're going
to
it doesn't matter
yeah